du sable une caravane de chameaux et en
arrière plan le petit train nous sommes
bien entendu c'est jean richard à la mer
de sable en pleine forêt d'ermenonville
comme chaque dimanche public est
nombreux pour voir ses vedettes
préférées
ce dimanche c'était l'équipe de sol à
paris avec bien entendu sophie agacinski
chaque dimanche en effet pendant un mois
encore des vedettes viendront ici pour
vendre des porte-clés ou profit des
vieux comédien de ris orangis et voici
le moment tant attendu par les fans de
cet hélicoptère va descendre johnny
hallyday qui sera accueilli par jean
richard et rené dail président de 9 de
secours aux vieux comédien
malgré la pluie l'enthousiasmé délirant
et johnny devra effectuer un tour
d'honneur à bord d'une minuscule
voitures d'ici quelques instants
vous le verrez en train de remettre à
randy d'harry un chèque destiné à l'ope
des vieux comédien dimanche prochain
d'autres vedettes viendront la mer de
sable ou vendre d'autres porte-clés
toujours au profit de ris orangis